understand that I am a rapper so you
know usually I'm like here are the rules
don't suggest [ __ ] suggestions I trust
you right you've come here because I
emailed you and you were like we'd love
to come and see that you you know that I
don't like [ __ ] suggestions making good
uh last night we had an abattoir for
gingers we have
the first two roads you're gonna get
suggestion number one what's
inspiring
an aspiring platypus estate agent is
that correct so are we saying that the
estate agent is a platypus or selling to
platypuses or platypus or butter pie
platypus the Platypus okay cool great
cool are they your favorite monitoring
uh yeah yeah
they wear they wear hats yeah platypuses
wear hats
[Music]
it says legal in Nevada
he's aspiring looks to be um let's come
to battle like Row three and four who's
got suggestion from over there pizza
pizza boxes in Romania Romanian pizza oh
okay for those of you that don't know
and uh Andrew Tate is allegedly a rapist
sex trafficker why are you guys see
[Music]
no no he's not no no Celebrity Big
Brother in 2016. he got thrown out
because he beat up a woman and then yeah
which already you're like why are you
picking on an autistic child right
in the video was like showing her his
nipple like a weird thing
and then he got arrested by the Romanian
authorities by showing them the pizza
box and that proved he was in Romania
they raised his house they took all his
cars he's in jail uh because he's a
rapist sex trafficker
exactly I mean that goes with the rapist
sex trafficking well I'll rape and a sex
tracking but I do put a coat down over a
puddle from time to time no they did and
then kick him
okay you know he's he's a he's a piece
of [ __ ]
um right so the remaining pizza boxes
very good aspiring platforms estate
agents let's come to middle of the room
what you guys want to rap about
it happened in the Year awards that
didn't happen of the Year Awards you
were all so online aren't you that is a
Twitter account where they they they
kind of mock people who tweet things and
they say it didn't have did one win this
year what was the one that won
um it was a
uh a lady went in the supermarket and
she was wearing a God Save the Queen
t-shirt or something at the whole
Supermarket burst into a chorus of God
Save the Queen
yeah
everyone Cuts apart from this young man
who's on crutches and he just stamped
his crotch
further back in the room
um what have you got what do I wrap up
Mary Barry a sex party yeah
I'm a big fan of the older lady
that's what I call Mary Berry hi No I um
she freaked when I lived in Oxford she
was frequently at this Farm Restaurant
that was quite nearby and I've seen her
there twice and she is [ __ ] smoking
in person the camera
in pounds she is oh she's slender
I'm so sorry no
that is not a phrase right it
occasionally like is that I think people
say nothing I made up right now she's
slender but it's about Mary Berry and I
think as you age as a woman you stop
being sexualized and I think you know
obviously you're like oh finally but
also there must be a little part of Mary
Berry that's like I did also used to
[ __ ] get it
um Mary Barry's hot that's all I'm
saying when she left crew leaders back
on right now not my type
which is that a sex party okay platypus
estate agent pizza boxes in Romania the
berry berry sex party and number three
was of course it was it didn't happen in
the air Awards course and then phase one
make it the best one don't make it
something that's gonna get me canceled
again like that despair air without a
care
despair no the spare despair air oh
Harry Prince Harry
there's bare air without a care you must
be give a [ __ ] does he why would you why
would you living in L.A he's living his
life his wife's smoking notice
horseberry
this is my thing now I [ __ ] oh it was
over seven who's drawing a state pension
that's what I want okay we're going to
do a rap about that
um rap time fixing [ __ ] noise
[Applause]
[Music]
screens nice tightria
won't happen over here it's a clear
winner walking in the supermarket round
Applause the Queen's t-shirt I started
applauding and crying from my eyes a guy
on the crutches wobble side to side he
can't touch his hands can't get palms
and so he starts with Chad dampy that's
the charm if the queen pass away and I
was in
[Music]
becoming like another one and on Twitter
it won all of the votes people say it
didn't happen they would vote and say
yes I'm gloating why cause I succeed if
I wanna see a little piece in the Reeds
with the tiny little beak like a duck I
say what this is [ __ ] crazy asking
the pricker what are you doing all we
can discuss I'm a real estate agent
platypus
your job well I'm just aspiring and so
when you do do you want to buy this
Willow that's just a tree I've listed it
on Zillow and zoopula and all the other
housing apps why is he looking smart
cause he wears a top hat with a very
Dapper guy walking around with his tail
like a beaver that's trying to be a bird
but has failed that's a monotreme the
other one not kidding you you've got the
platter persons and you've got the
Echidna they're like a hedgehog yeah I'm
a rapper who can talk about monitoring
Chloe
passage they put out the egg you're
nodding like very wise words that he
said
I've never little boy I like him maybe I
would employ him not in a lab well it's
a shame there he could be flipping
pizzas out in Romania you don't flip
pieces as Burgers but [ __ ] I get their
little box and I package it up I take it
out to a mansion the dude won't wait
he's like put it on my plate I'm Andrew
Tate he doesn't sound like that he
sounds [ __ ] so inflated he goes how
long have I waited I wanted yeah I like
sexy foxes I like [ __ ] and pizza
boxes I put it open oh [ __ ] now they're
coming in Romanian police raid in my
house yeah it's better than the rest
when you're out in Bucharest people like
Andrew Tate put the prick to the test a
misogynist slightly like me when I was
riding out harder very very
into the basement remain here it's so
dark so kimchi the walls are so damp I
look around I feel just like a chap I've
got my chain got my whip got all of my
latex I see overhead Victorious Bunch
who made it I looked to my left and I
plunged my finger my gosh how Airy is
this
jam with all the caster sugar on the top
my plan goes out the window I get a
reptile because I see the woman who'll
be setting that technical from the baker
I take off my clothes very very like
you'll be in a bad boy
show me Chris she leans in gives me the
tiniest of kisses then she runs away
she's playing hard to get Mary barrier
she ain't a [ __ ] sketch she's the
hottest lady on the BBC although she's
not being on it recently but that's fine
who's that there in the air killing
Taliban soldiers that air without a
chair he's despair from 25 Checkers off
the board really Harry are you really
quite sure that you want to equate human
life to chess pieces he says I don't
care if it moves if I see it I've done
it down I do it for the military this is
less funny than Mary Berry so we'll go
back there in the dungeon
foreign
Berry dildo I don't want a handshake
from you you're a loser and I say wow I
like Mary Barry [ __ ] Paul he's a [ __ ]
scouse